foreign
has a very long history and relationship
with Afghanistan that spans you know
decades and generations and yet Afghans
have this unfamiliarity with Britain and
its system and its values
um and so
I've been back to Afghanistan for many
years uh over the last 20 and sort of
every year over two years and one thing
I can safely say uh when people ask me
have we failed in Afghanistan
my instant response and one that I've
heard very commonly uh Acro from from
young people in Afghanistan is that no
Britain and the West did not fail in
Afghanistan a lot had had changed
um we had seen illiteracy rates
skyrockets women were in public uh uh
mainstream Society they were in a
university there were coffee shops I
mean I remember going to Afghanistan the
first time in 2006 I remember
stepping into the airport and I was
wrapped up with a scarf a lot more
tighter than a young girl who lived
there and I was terrified I was like oh
my God it's scary it's it's this is a
country that's been in Wharf for
generations and you know this is a
country that's known for extremism and
terrorism I was actually scared and I
wore sort of a hijab and properly
covered and I when I entered the city of
Kabul they were girls with my the sky I
mean it was interesting their scarves
were falling down their hair there was a
lot more hair being shown tops were much
shorter jeans and they just walked
around Kabul City
um as if it's I don't know southbourne
in London and I was honestly inspired I
knew that there was something that these
these young people were were striving
for and Afghanistan as many other
countries in the developing world is
dominated uh by sort of a Young
Generation about 75 of Afghanistan's
population is under 25 I think the
average age is 18. so many of them have
never even lived on the Taliban rule
this was a whole new generation and a
country that wanted and to and wanted to
accept I guess Western values or British
values of democracy of a freedom of
equality and tolerance
um and I think what we actually failed
in the failure is less that we didn't
win the war the failure was that we
didn't have the patience and the
commitment I mean what is it how can you
expect a country that had no
infrastructure had was basically a blank
canvas in 2001 there are no hotels no
roads no schools and you expect it after
20 years to stand on its own two feet
and to figure it out on its uh by on its
own Afghanistan's always been a foreign
aid dependent country
uh historically it's never had its own
economy unfortunately I think it's I
mean I can go back to the history of
Afghanistan but it will take much longer
uh unfortunately the foundations and and
in 1747 when Afghanistan was created it
wasn't created to be a modern State and
that's where the problem starts it's a
very tribal traditional Society made up
of many different ethnic groups who
struggle to unite and the one thing they
actually United and were able to sort of
sit on the same umbrella under was
democracy it was the freedom to vote the
freedom to elect their own government
their own leaders hold them to account a
free media where I think in in the last
20 years Afghanistan had the most open
media than even Pakistan or many other
Central Asian countries Iran for example
as well many other neighboring countries
were inspired at how openly critical the
Afghan media was of its own leaders for
fear of no fear of of repercussions uh
whereas you know currently is completely
the opposite but there was there was a
lot of hope and every time I traveled I
saw more difference and more security
and and a better and a better future for
the country and
last year August I think it shocked not
only the people of Afghanistan but the
world that we'd entered a point where
we've completely lost hope that
Afghanistan could ever be changed and
the narrative shifted you know people
started to believe that the people of
Afghanistan didn't want and didn't
accept our our values and our and
democracy and for some reason I was very
confused I thought actually
the evidence says differently why is the
narrative changing why is the media
saying that we failed why is the media
making it seem like the Afghan people
didn't want us and they accepted the
Taliban where it was actually the
country it wasn't the the Afghan people
didn't fight first of all Afghanistan
had an army of about 400 000 and I'm
sure you may recall but after 2013 we
didn't hear any more British soldiers
being killed in Afghanistan or injured
because after 2013 the NATO forces and
British forces were basically there as
morale as a support system as as a
mechanism or system where you provide
training and Equipment but you weren't
we weren't fighting the Afghan forces
were fighting and we were simply there
to ensure that they were they were on
the Battleground and they were fighting
terrorism every day which many Afghans
wanted to the problem started when I
when the forces were told to put their
weapons down because and it was again
the government had many problems over
the years corruption was one of it
salaries weren't being paid and to be
honest when everyone the world has step
aside and said we don't want to do
anything here anymore we've given hope
how can you expect Afghan forces who
most of them live in poverty to fight I
mean right now in Ukraine where we're
sending billions in Aid and equipment
and weapons and yet you expect it in a
country like Afghanistan to fight on its
own it's bizarre it was honestly I think
not only did it feel offensive but it
felt like we didn't understand
Afghanistan right from the beginning we
didn't understand its people we didn't
understand its history it's geography
what the country represented and where
it came from and so 20 years on in uh in
August last year 15th the world decided
it didn't matter anymore and we've had
enough and we don't want to do anything
here I understand billions in AIDS were
invested lives countless lives were lost
it was a very very difficult task to be
in Afghanistan and to fight extremism
and terrorism and this barbaric backward
mentality
but we also need to understand that
Afghanistan is the heart of Asia
why did we go to Afghanistan in the
first place we acknowledge the security
in Afghanistan meant security not only
in the region but globally it's always
been the case
there were mistakes that were made I
mean that's evident in terms of our
foreign policy in terms of our
International Aid our interventionism
how we actually set about introducing
Western values to Afghanistan but it
what I think I'm trying to say is that
it just needed reform and change and
understanding it didn't it didn't
require us to take a step back Retreat
and give up altogether and the fear
right now I mean I'm sure you've all
been reading the news
um in September last year when the
Taliban came back to Afghanistan
people said well this is Taliban 2.0
this is a different Taliban this is a
different
group and they have governance uh
administrative skills now and they'll be
able to run a country
actually the country is true they have
better PR
they use social media now they're on
Twitter spaces which is really
interesting you go on Twitter space you
will hear a Taliban either a Taliban
spokesperson or a supporter there or one
of their members actually in a Twitter
space communicating to the general
International audience that's what's
changed about the Taliban they've
modernized with technology but their
ideology hasn't changed we're almost two
months away from one year of Taliban
takeover and Afghan women
have been forced to wear the burka or
the hijab
they've been told to stay at home or to
avoid leaving the house unless it's very
very necessary
they've told women don't really have the
need to work
um unless it's you know very exceptional
circumstances women are now being
slowly removed from TV I think just only
two weeks ago there were four there were
ordered to wear veils or masks on
national TV
they're banned from school
at primary age just last week I was
shocked to hear that girls who go to
primary schools aged between 9 and 12
should be wearing a face Veil should
cover their faces there is no one
there's not one Muslim country in the
world that you can name to me right now
where women are forced at such a young
age to wear
a face Veil it's a child
and beyond that we have poverty at such
a high level where 97 of the population
is almost starving
it's a human tragedy uh sort of
unfolding
we have different ethnic groups being
persecuted
by the Taliban those who had any former
affiliations with the British government
with NATO with the International
Community the former Army officials
um
those who worked with International
agencies ngos anyone that showed support
for our work in Afghanistan
are either detained killed and
you never hear of them again there was
actually one case that really struck me
where a mother a performer police
officer female police officer in
Afghanistan was taken from our home
and shot right in front of her family
members outside her home I mean this is
this is what we've ended up doing how do
we not realize what a mistake it was
this this didn't need to happen
and what we also seem to fail to
understand is that security in
Afghanistan will and is already slowly
entering neighboring countries
the Taliban have attacked already I
think
Uzbekistan they've attacked Tajikistan
they're entering the Iranian borders
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas